اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نستكمل معكم هذه
التغطيه المباشره حول تفجير سد نوفا
كخوفكا في اخر التطورات افاد مسؤول مدعوم
من روسيا لوكاله الروسيه للانباء بتدمير
سنوبك خوف قد ضخم والواقع في الاجزاء التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا في منطقه خرسون جنوب
اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان لا خطوره على محطات
زابوريا وتشير الانباء الان ان الخطوره
بالفعل بدات على محطه النوويه بعد تفجير
السد واوضح رئيس بلديه نوفاكاخوف كان معين
من قبل روسيا ان الجزء العلوي من السد
التامه تدميره نتيجه القصف مشددا ان تدمير
السد السد هو يؤدي الى مشاكل في امدادات
المياه في جزيره القرم اما مقاطع مصوره
فقد كشفت ارتفاع منسوب مياه نهر دنيبرو ل
18 امتار بحسب الصحفي محمد البابا بعد
استهداف سد نوفكا فيما اكد مسؤولون محليون
ان المياه بدات تغمر العديد من القرى على
النهر فيما تم اجلاء سكان ما لا يقل عن
300 من المنازل حتى الان
طيب ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد البابا من كيف
اهلا بك معنا محمد اذا الخطوره على محطه
زبريج النوويه بدات بالفعل بحسب الانباء
انقل لنا المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول ذلك
نعم يعني خلال يعني متابعتنا خلال الدقائق
الماضيه هناك كما يتداول ست كره قد غمرتها
المياه جزئيا او كليا بفعل تدمير جسر نوفي
كخوفكا ست كره تقع بالضفه الغربيه لنهر
نيبر في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها السلطات
الاوكرانيه عمليه الاجلاء من السلطات
المحليه في مقاطعه خرسونوجيا بدات بالفعل
وذلك لمساعده السكان على نقل ملابسهم
واحتياجاتهم ونقلهم الى مناطق ابعد على
بعد 20 الى 30 كيلومتر من المنطقه
المنكوبه يعني حاله حاله انسانيه او كارثه
انسانيه صعبه بدات تتشكل في تلك المنطقه
في مدينه خرسون الدعوه حتى ان الشرطه بدات
تسير بين المنازل وتدعو السكان الى
الاجلاء الفوري من مدينه خرسون بعد يعني
اقتراب منسوب المياه للارتفاع في محيط تلك
المدينه معظم المدن التي الكره التي تقع
في المنطقه في المنطقه الغربيه
اعتذر في المنطقه الغربيه
لنهر النيبر بدات ترتفع منسوب المياه بحسب
مصادر محليه منسوب المياه ارتفع الى حدود
18 مترا المياه تدخل الى الكره وتستمر
الفيضان لانه يعني ما يحدث الان هو مثل
فيضان يستمر بالتمدد من القريه الى قريه
جنوبا باتجاه جنوب اكثر جنوب مقاطعه
خرسوان القوات الاوكرانيه القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه اكدت ان القوات الروسيه هي من
قامت بتفخيخ وتفجير جسر النهر او سد انوفا
كخوفكا ومحطه
الجانب الروسي
ابقى معي محمد لانتقل الى موسكو وعبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك معنا عبد الجواد اذا
اتهامات اوكرانيه بان الجانب الروسي هو من
قام بتفجير هذا السد وهذه الكارثه البيئيه
الاولى من نوعها عبد الجواد ما اراد
الروسي حول ذلك
مرحبا فاطمه ملكي ولمحمد يعني حتى هذه
اللحظه ما زالت موسكو ملتزمه الصمت نوعا
ما بما يخص قضيه
تفجير او ضرب يعني محطه نوفا كخوفه لكن
السلطات المغاليه لروسيا في تلك المناطق
ان كانت طبعا السلطات زبروج او سلطات
خيرسون او حتى عمده مدينه
يتحدثون عن ان ضربه اوكرانيه ادت لهذه
الكارثه حتى هذه اللحظه الاخبار الوارده
من هناك تتحدث عن ارتفاع منسوب المياه الى
عشره امتار في نهر دنيبر والى يعني ثمانيه
او خمسه امتار في مناطق اخرى بدات بالفعل
عمليه الاجلاء لبعض المناطق السكنيه
المجاوره هذا عنه رسميا عمده مدينه خرسون
الموالي طبعا لروسيا ايضا بما يخص قضيه
شبه جزيره القرم والتي يدور الحديث عنها
كثيرا بما يخص هذه الضربه ايضا خرج حاكم
هذه الجزيره وتحدث بانه لا يوجد تهديد
بغرق او فيضانات قد تحدث في شبه الجزيره
لكن المشكله تكمن في ان القناه المائيه
التي تزوج شبه جزيره القرم ستشح فيها
المياه بشكل كبير خلال الفترات القادمه
طبعا هو خرج وطمان وتحدث للسكان عن وجود
مياه صالحه للشرب تكفي الجميع لكن القناه
المائيه امام خطر الشوح فيها في تلك
المنطقه قضيه طبعا
كنت اسالك عبد الجواد عن يعني ما تبعات او
امكانيه اصلاح هذا السد يعني يقال بان
الجزء العلوي هو ما تضرر ولكن الى اي مدى
هو كبير هذا الضرر والى اي مدى يمكن يعني
اصلاحه
فاطمه يعني التقارير الرسميه لم تخرج بعد
بما يخص هذا الموضوع لكن التوقعات
للشخصيات الرسميه لحكومه في تلك المنطقه
نتحدث عن ان هذا الجسر وهذه المحطات يعني
تعرضت لضرر كبير لا يمكن اصلاحه بطريقه
سريعه ولا بطريقه شبه سريعه نوعا ما يحتاج
لفترات وعمل وجهد وتقنيات طويله باعتبار
ان هذه المحطه هي الاكبر في المنطقه هناك
كانت يعني كان الشد يضم او يخفي وراءه
كميات كبيره من المياه وهذه المياه بدات
تخرج يعني حتى هذه اللحظه الجميع بانتظار
كارثه الحديث يدور عن قرابه 80 منطقه
سكنيه وقريه قد تطالها عمليه الغرق لذلك
اتجهت سلطات المدينه نحو الاجلاء نعم
بالفعل يعني ما يفسر نوعا ما حسب روايه
البعض يعني
سكوت موسكو حتى هذه اللحظه بما يخص
التصريحات الرسميه هو المشكله الكبيره
الذي احدثها احدثتها هذه الضربه لذلك طبعا
نحن امام
التقرير رسمي قد تخرج به موسكو سلسله من
التصريحات الكبيره خاصه انك هي تلقي اللوم
على موسكو في هذه القضيه لكن طبعا كما
تحدثت موسكو مره بانها هي من تسيطر على
المنطقه هناك الجميع يذكر فاطمه طبعا
عندما زارت كاميرا العربيه تلك المنطقه
بصراحه عندما كنا نمشي فوق هذا الجسر يعني
كنا نلاحظ
خياليه ورحبه المنظر وسرعه تدفق المياه
لذلك الحديث يدور عن اعطال لا يمكن
السيطره عليها بالقوه البشريه او المعدات
في هذه اللحظه باعتبار ان كميات المياه هي
كبيره جدا يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لم تسجل
ارقام وفيات او غير ذلك لكن يعني كما هو
متوقع باننا امام كارثه كبيره قد تطال
الكثير من المناطق غرق العديد من الاراضي
السكنيه في
المناطق الزراعيه هذا ما سيؤدي الى تلف
الى نقص النقص المحصول الى هجره السكان
الى اعمال يعني اخرى باعتبار ان عمليه
الاجلاء ستكون واسعه واسعه النطاق عمليه
الاجلاء ايضا بحد ذاتها ستكون عبئا على
موسكو عبئا على السلطات المواليه هناك ما
هي المناطق التي سيتجه اليها هؤلاء
المواطنين باعتبار ان المنطقه تعيش حاله
وضع عسكري غير مسبوقه خلال فتره الصراع
خاصه مع بدء الهجوم الاوكراني نحو تلك
المنطقه تفضلي فاطمه طيب عبد الجواد يعني
بعد هذا الهجوم الذي تتهم موسكو اوكرانيا
بالقيام به هل هي توقن بان الهجوم المضاده
الاوكراني بالفعل بدا كيف تتناول هذا
الموضوع الصحف الروسيه
وكما يعني الموضوع هنا يحمل يحمل الشطين
حسب الروايه الروسيه رسميا لم تعلن موسكو
عن ان هذا الهجوم المضاد التي الذي دار
الحديث عنه قد بدا بالفعل لكنها تحدثت عن
الهجمه الاوكرانيه في هذه الفتره هي قويه
لم تشهدها عمليه الصراع من قبل
اريد الداخلي
ين في وسائل الاعلام او يتداوله المواطنون
الجميع يتحدث عن ان الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد قد بدا منذ نحو عشره ايام هي مناطق
طبعا مناطق الساخنه اصبحت في بلغراد في
الشريط الحدودي في كورسكا المسيرات التي
طالت موسكو وضواحيها وغيرها
والكثير من هذه المناطق اصبحت تشهد ضربات
اوكرانيه لذلك الكثير اصبحوا يوقنون هذا
الموضوع هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى موسكو
يعني وجدت نفسها اليوم امام اعلان نظام
يعني نظام الحرب او نظام
العمليه العسكريه ورفع مستواها دون
الاعلان الرسمي يعني تطور الاوضاع
الازمه بشكل سريع جعل من الوضع في روسيا
الان يتحول الى وضع الشبه عسكري ان كان
بالاقتصاد او
بالاحتياطات او الشريط الحدودي او تجهيز
الجنود او الصناعه العسكريه دون اعلان
رسمي من موسكو لذلك الوضع هو خطير جدا
فاطمه حط هذه اللحظه لا يمكن الحديث كيف
ستكون رده فعل موسكو ان كانت بالتصريحات
او كانت بالضربات على ما يبدو بان
بيان وزاره الدفاع اليوم سيتطرق للحديث
مباشره عن هذا الموضوع اما طبعا اسس
الروسي كانوا على مستوى او الخارجيه او
مجلس الامن سيتحدثون عن هذه الازمه وقد
يذهب مجلس الامن الروسي بالحديث عن ضربات
وان الجانب الغربي اوصل موسكو لمرحله يمكن
يعني الرجوع بها او الجلوس الى طاوله
الحوار في القريب العاجل طيب ابقى معي عبد
الجواد لاعود الى كييفو صحفي محمد البابا
وانطلاقا من هذه الهجمات
المضاده التي تتحدث عنها عبد الجواد اعود
اليكم محمد يعني هذه الهجمات هل من
معلومات في الداخل الاوكراني تشير ربما
الى تغيير اوكرانيا في حساباتها فيما يخص
الهجوم المضاد بعد هذه الكارثه او ربما
حتى هجومها بشكل عام في مسار الحرب
نعم فاطمه حتى هذه اللحظه يعني لا بيانات
تخرج من وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
تغيير استراتيجي في الخطط العسكريه ولكن
يعني ما نعلمه ان الرئيس الاوكراني يجتمع
مع مجلس الدفاع مع المجلس الامن والدفاع
الاعلى الاوكراني بحضور رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني لمناقشه تداعيات هذا التفجير
تفجير جسر لذلك القوات الاوكرانيه تعي
تماما انه يعني مرحله قبل تفجير سد نوفل
كخوفكا ليست كمرحله بعد تفجير سد نفك خفقه
مما يعني انه سيكون هناك تغييرات يعني
ميدانيه تغييرات بالخطط خاصه ان يعني
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني وكما كان يتداول
هناك بعض النقاط الرئيسيه والمدن الرئيسيه
مثل ميليتوبل مثل بريديانس وماريوبول هي
من اهداف العمليه العسكريه الاوكرانيه من
اهداف الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني خلال يعني
الفتره المق ولكن بسبب هذا التفجير ستكون
المرحله يعني خلال الاسابيع القليله
المقبله سيكون هناك صعوبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه بالقيام بعمليات بريه في تلك
المنطقه بعدما تكون المياه قد غمرت مساحات
جغرافيه كبيره لذلك احد السيناريوهات التي
يتم التداول بها في وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه وحتى في وسائل عسكريه في وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان هذا التفجير احد اهم
اسبابه تفجير سد نوفل والفيضان الذي سيحدث
والذي سيخلف كارثه انسانيه وبيئيه كبيره
جدا احد اهم اسباب الفيضان محمد على ما
يبدو الاضرار في تزايد يعني دقيقه بدقيقه
مصادر العربيه تتحدث عن اربع تربونات
لمحطه نوفاكا خوف كجنوب اوكرانيا تم
تدميرها بالكامل وهناك اخطار تتزايد ايضا
على محطه زابوريجيا يعني محمد او اسالك عن
محطه زابوريجيا تحديدا كم تبعد عن هذا
السد وما مدى الضر الذي يمكن ان يلحق بها
اثر تفجير هذا السد وتدميره اولا يعني
محطه
الكهرومائيه هي تولد التيار او تعطي حوالي
60% الى 70% من قدره مفاعل النووي من
القدره الكهربائيه لذلك الان بدات خطه
الطوارئ عبرت يعني
تمديد او اعطاء الطاقه الكهربائيه من
المولدات الخاصه التي تقع داخل مفاعل
النووي ولكن يعني النقطه المهمه هي في حال
انخفاض منسوب المياه في بحيره
والتي يعني يجب ان يكون الحد الادنى من
المياه هو 16 مترا الان الحد الادنى من
المياه هو 16 ونصف اي انخفض قليلا منسوب
المياه في تلك البحيره او البركه التي
يعني تستخدم المياه فيها لتبريد يعني
المفاعل النوويه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
الاداره الشركه المشغله تقول ان حتى هذه
اللح الامور تحت السيطره ولكن هناك تهديد
فعلي بحسب السلطات الاوكرانيه وما يتداول
في وزاره الطاقه الاوكرانيه انه في حاله
استمر انخفاض منسوب المياه قد تؤثر على
يعني تبريد المفاعل النووي مما قد يؤدي
الى خروج اشعاعات نوويه من هذا المفاعل
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه كل المعلومات تقول ان
الامور تحت السيطره حتى هذه اللحظه لكن من
ناحيه اخرى من ناحيه اخرى يعني محطه
الكهرومائيه هي تولد الكهرباء لمساحات
شاسعه من تلك المنطقه وتعتبر من اكبر
المحطات الكهرومائيه في اوكرانيا تم تدمير
الجزء الاهم فيها وهي التوربينات التي
تولد الطاقه من اندفاع المياه عبر هذا
السد تم تدمير اربع تورربينات من اصل ست
تربينات ما يعني ان المحطه قد فقدت قوتها
الرئيسيه اضافه الى تدمير يعني حوالي 11
حائطا من
يعني 18 حائطا تحجز المياه لان يعني السد
ليس فقط هو سد يعني عبر
البلوكات الاسمنتيه بل هو ساب ايضا عبر
يعني الامتداد الجغرافي للبحيره ولكن
الجزء الاكبر من السد احد عشر حائط من اصل
ثمانيه عشر قد دمر من الجهه الفوقيه لا
احد يعلم يعني الاضرار لا تستطيع السلطات
الاوكرانيه احصاء الاضرار بشكل كامل في
تلك المنطقه لانها منطقه تقع تحت سيطره
الاحتلال الروسي بحسب
المحيطه فيه من الجهه الغربيه من الجهه
الجنوبيه كيف تتاثر
نعم المنطقه الغربيه بدات المياه ترتفع
وتنتقل يعني تدريجيا المياه تنتقل من
منطقه الى منطقه جنوبا منسوب المياه ارتفع
يعني الكره القريبه من نوفيكا من الجهه
الغربيه اصبحت المياه تدخلها وقد وصلنا
عدد كبير من تسجيلات الفيديو نرى كيف
المياه تدخل الى المنازل السكنيه الى
الساحات الى الطرقات حتى ان بعض التسجيلات
الفيديو كان كنا نرى سيارات تمشي مثل نهر
بسبب ارتفاع منسوب المياه المياه تتجه
جنوبا باتجاه المدن وباتجاه مدينه خرسون
التي تقع مباشره على الضفه الشرقيه على
الضفه الغربيه لنهر وهي ستكون من المدن
الاكبر في اوكرانيا التي ستتاثر بسبب
فيضان المياه فيضان المياه بسبب يعني جسر
نوفي فهو يحجز كما ذكر يعني عبد الجواد
كميات كبيره من المياه يفوق 18 مليون
مليمتر مكعب يعني ما يكفي لتمر مساحات جغ
تفوق العشرين الى اربعين الى خمسين كيلو
متر مربع في يعني على طول نهر
اضافه انه الان يعني بعد فتره اشياء وفي
فتره الربيع مزيدا عن هذه التداعيات
والمخاوف محمد ابقى معي لنتابع مشاهدينا
هذه الصور الاوليه لانهيار سد كخوف نوفا
كخوفكا
[موسيقى]
شراء
اذا مشاهدينا يعني مياه منسوب مياه النهر
ترتفع الى اكثر من عشره امتار وانباء
تتحدث عن ثمانيه عشر متر حتى اللحظه يعني
هذا يشير الى كارثه بيئيه غير مسبوقه في
المنطقه قد يتاثر فيها احياء سكنيه 80 حيث
سكني تحديدا 300 منزل ربما سيتم اخلاقه
كارثه واسعه النطاق تفجرت في اوكرانيا
اليوم ستغير لا محاله خارطه الحرب وقد
تغير معها ايضا حسابات اوكرانيا بالنسبه
للهجوم المضاد فما كانت تخشاه كييف تحقق
بالفعل انهيار سد نوفاكا خوفك جنوب
اوكرانيا بعد تفجيره بقصف تتبادل روسيا
واوكرانيا الاتهامات بالوقوف ورائهم السد
الواقع في الاجزاء التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
في خرسون سنتحدث بعد قليل عن موقع السد
واهميته الاستراتيجيه يشكل تدميره خطرا
كبيرا على مناطق جنوب اوكرانيا ويعرض الاف
المدنيين للخ حتى الان المياه في محيط
نوبك خوفك ارتفعت اكثر من عشره امتار
وغمرت قرى محيطه بحسب وكاله الانباء
الروسيه نيانو فيستي التي اعلنت ايضا ان
22 الف شخص واربعه عشر حيث سكني تاثروا
بالفيضان بعد استهداف السد فيما حذر
مسؤولون محليون بان اكثر من 90 قريه مهدده
بالغرق و 300 منزل مهدد بالانهيار في
منطقه الفيضان
[موسيقى]
وامام هذه المشاهد لانهيار السد
والتحذيرات من تبعاته الكارثيه اعلن حاكم
منطقه خرسون اوليكس عن البدء بعمليات
اخلاء المناطق القريبه من منطقه كخوفك في
جنوب البلاد محذرا من ان وصول منسوب
المياه الى مستوى حرج خلال الساعات
القادمه سيكون كارثيا من كيف معنا
الدبلوماسي والمستشار السابق فولدمير شو
ماكو اهلا بك معنا فلاديمير شوماكوف سيد
فلاديمير يعني تفجير هذا السد وارتفاع
منسوب المياه الى مستويات مخيفه حقيقه الى
ماذا يشير وكيف ربما يؤثر على مسار الحرب
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اخواني
تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا
للاسف الشديد نحن نشاهد بان روسيا وخاصه
بوتن بيستحواذ الشيطان يرغب تدمير
اوكرانيا
بصراحه هذا الكارثه روسيا ضمرت ليس فقط هي
كمان هناك
مواليدات داخل هذا داخل هذا المحطه
كهربائيه من المنتظر بصراحه ارتفاع منصوب
المياه الى 12 مترا
وتفجير ساط يهدد بادراك حوالي 80 بلده في
محافظه اخرسون داخل مدينه خرسون فيها
عمليات الاجلاء الاجلاءات كمان لا توجد
كهربائي في مدينه خيرسون وفي محافظه خرسون
وايضا هناك من المياه الشوربه هذا
انسانيه وخسائر خساره اكثر من مليارات من
خمسه مليار دولار تقريبا يعني لكل حاجه
نحن نشاهد بان روسيا
تترغيب التوقف وتعرق للهجوم قوات مصالحه
وكريميه في ان واحد عندي شواغل جديه بان
قبل
التورمين محافظه
روسيا سوف تدمر محاطه نوويه في هذا
المنطقه وهذا عمل انتقام لروسي
لشعب الاوكراني ولجيش اوكرانيا بصفه عامه
هذا كارثه كبيره
هذه الكارثه الخطيره كما تصفها نراها لغه
روسيه والله ما هي سخريه من تسمعني يوم
لغه روسيه في ايام حرب وايضا عندما حدثت
هذا الكارثه في مدينه خرسون وفي محافظه
خرسون طيب سيد يعني هذه الكارثه هل ربما
تؤدي الى تراجع
وتراجع الجيش الاوكراني عن هذا الهجوم
المضاد او ربما اعاده حساباتهم بما انهم
يتهمون الروس بالقيام بهذا التفجير على
السد انا لا اعتقد بان سوف يكون اي ضرر
كبير كما للجيش روسي كمالي جيش اوكرانيا
هذا الضرر كبير لسكان هذا المحافظات
ولكن الجانب الاوكراني اقال بانهم بان
تفجير السد يعيق التقدم الاوكراني في
الهجوم المضاد
طيب سيد ولكن الجانب الاوكراني اشار بان
تفجير هذا السد سيعيق التقدم الاوكراني
فيما يخص الهجوم المضاد
نعم من المنتظر يعني لن تكون هجوم المضاد
قوات مصالحه اوكرانيه من قبل مدينه
الخرسون من قبل الضفه الغربيه ولكن اكيد
ممكن سوف يكون هجوم المضادات في محافظه
تفجير سوف يعرقل هجوم مصالحه في جنوب
اوكرانيا يعني من محافظه خرسان طيب ابقى
معي السيده انتقل الى موسكو وينضم الينا
الكاتب السياسي بسام البني اهلا بك معنا
بسام السيد بسام يعني برايك المتضرر
الاكبر من تفجير هذا السد هل الجانب
الروسي ام الاوكراني
اسعد الله صباحك استاذي فاطمه بكل تاكيد
يعني هو الجانب الروسي المتضرر لاننا كما
نعلم البحيره التي تقع خلفك تزوج شبه
جزيره الكرنب بالمياه العذبه اضف الى ذلك
انها يعني تضر بالمصالح الروسيه لان انا
الاحظ ان هناك حمله اعلاميه غربيه بدات
على الفور باتهام روسيا بارتكاب جريمه حرب
وارتفاع الاصوات هناك من جديد
بشان انسحار القوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اريد ان اذكر هنا حقيقه بان
القوات النظام كيف استهدفت هذا السد على
مدى عام كامل يعني اذا ما رجعنا راجعنا
تصريحات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كان هناك
اكثر من 100 مره تم ذكر
السد كخوفكا بان قواته كلايما تستهدفه
بصواريخ الهايمرز وغيرها من الصواريخ من
اجل
حصار القوات الروسيه هناك بعد ان سحبت
قوات الروسيه الان نلاحظ ان الهجوم المضاد
المزعوم قد فشل وقد خسرت البارحه اوكرانيا
حوالي
109 اليه عسكريه ثقيله في جنوب دانيسك
ومنها من
دبابات اليوبارد ومدرعات فرنسيه ثلاثه
والباقي من صناعه سوفيتيه هذا يعني ان
اوكرانيا تريد ان تقدم عذرا للغرب لماذا
لا تستطيع القيام بالهجوم المضاد لان كان
الهدف هو الوصول الى ميناتوبيل ومن ثم الى
بحر ازوف وهذه الخطه الاوكرانيه قد اعلن
عنها مرارا وتكرارا هذا يعني ان اوكرانيا
وجدت لنفسها الزريعه بانها لا تستطيع
القيام بهذا الهجوم المضاد هو رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي يقول في العاجل امامنا السيد
بسام بان الهجوم على سد نوفاكا خوف كفي
اوكرانيا عمل غير مسبوق ابقوا معي ضيوف
الكرام لنتعرف على اهميه الموقع
الاستراتيجي لهذا السد
اذا ما هي نقطه الضعف الكبرى في جنوب
اوكرانيا سد نوفا كخوفكا في خرسون الواقعه
تحت سيطره روسيا والذي تكمن اهميته في
موقع في موقعه الاستراتيجي عندنا نهر
دنيبرو رابع اطول نهر في قاره اوروبا يقع
سد نوفا كخوفكا على بعد 30 كيلومتر شرق
مدينه خيرسون يبلغ ارتفاعه 30 متر وعرضه
مئات الامتار بني في عام
1950 ثم تم تشغيله بعد ست سنوات كجزء من
محط نوفاك خوفكا للطاقه الكهرومائيه
وقوعه على نهر الدنيا برو مشاهدينا يعني
انه يحتجز كميات كبيره من المياه تصل الى
18 مليون متر مكعب اي انه وباختصار يولد
الكهرباء في المناطق الجنوبيه وكذلك يسقي
قنوات الري اما عن نهر دنيبرو فينبع من
مرتفعات فلادي في روسيا
ويعبر بيلاروسيا ومنها الى اوكرانيا في
مدينه دنيفرو بتروفيس حيث يصب في البحر
الاسود اذا هذا اهميه الموقع الاستراتيجي
لانها يعني عبد الجواد اذهب الى موسكو
ومراسله من هناك عبد الجواد الرشد اهميه
هذا الموقع بالنسبه
لروسيا واهميه هذا السد بالنسبه لهم يعني
هل يعقل ان تقوم بتفجير هذا السد الذي يقع
في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا وسمعنا
قبل قليل عن اهميته بالنسبه للروس
مرحبا فاطمه لك ولضيوفك الكرام نعم في
الحقيقه يعني الكثير من الاصوات الان
والقراءات السياسيه والتحليليه على وسائل
الاعلام الروسي او في مواقع التواصل
الداخليه الحديث فيها يدور عن هذا الموضوع
والضربه التي وجهتها القوات الاوكرانيه
الى هذا الى هذه المحطه حسب الروايه
الرسميه الروسيه للسلطات المواليه في تلك
المناطق طبعا نبدا من الامور الميدانيه
هناك ما زالت حكومه خرسون رسميا على لسان
عمدتها تتحدث بان مستويات المياه هي جاريه
في ارتفاع في نهر دنيبر الحد الذي وصلت
اليه الان يزيد عن عشره امتار تقريبا
بينما تتسع رقعه المناطق
المتضرره والتي يحدث فيها فيضانات نوعا ما
وتقوم المياه بتغطيه الاراضي الزراعيه
المنازل البيوت بالنسبه طبعا لما سالتي
وطرحته فاطمه طبعا الحديث في الداخل
الروسي يدور عن انه كيف لموسكو القيام
بهذه العمليه وتحميل نفسها عبء قرابه من
50 الى 60 الف شخص قد يتضرروا من تلك
الحادثه وقد تضطر موسكو والسلطات المواليه
في خرسون لاجلائهم الى مناطق اخرى وما هي
المناطق التي سيصل اليها هؤلاء الاشخاص
وما يمكن فعله لاجله لاجلهم لذلك طبعا
الوضع كما تصفه السلطه في تلك المنطقه كما
يدور الحديث عنه الان في وسائل الاعلام
وفي مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ما يقوم
بنشره السكان المحليون على تيليجرام وعلى
غيرها من المواقع يتحدث عن ان المنطقه
هناك مقبله على كارثه نوعا ما بدءا من
يعني خراب الاراضي الزراعيه نزوح كميه
كبيره من السكان قد تزيد عن 50 الف شخص
تضرر
ابقى معي عبد الجواد طبعا نذكر بالعواجي
المشاهدين حيث قالت كيف بانها وضعت خطه
للطوارئ لضمان استمرار امدادات المياه الى
محطه زابوريجيا وان هناك فعلا تهديد على
المحطه ولكن الوضع حتى الان تحت السيطره
فيما يخص الامدادات للمحطه ونذكر بان
ارتفاع منسوب المياه بلغ اكثر من عشره
امتار في النوبه كخوفكا نعود الى ضيوفي من
كييف الدبلوماسيه والمستشار السابق
فلاديمير ومن موسكو الكاتب السياسي بسام
البني ابدا معك السيد فلاديمير شوماكوف
يعني
اشرتم الى نقطه مهمه اشار اليها سيد بسام
قبل قليل بان الاعلام الغربي قام فورا
باتهام روسيا بارتكاب جرائم حرب كذلك
واوكرانيا قاموا بالفعل يعني بهجوم اعلامي
كبير وشرس على روسيا مقابل صمت روسي حتى
الان بحسب مراسل هناك عبد الجواد لا
تعليقات من روسيا وكانهم يشير المحللين
والبعض يقول بانهم يقيمون الوضع يقيمون
الاضرار ويقيمون هذه الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه في الهجوم المضاد كيف ترد على
ذلك سيد فلاديمير يعني الاتهامات هذه
السريعه والمتتاليه هل تشير الى ربما
علمهم المسبق بتفجير السد
لا توجد اي معصله اوكرانيه لتفجير هذا
الساق بصراحه لان عندنا الكارثه على نطاق
واسع حول تصريحات ضيوف من روسيا في الضرر
للجيش روسيا لا يوجد اي ضرر هناك للجيش
روسيا لان اغلبيه القوات الروسيه موجوده
في عمق
المحافظه على ضيفه شرقيه يعني هذا الضرر
كبير اكيد لاوكرانيا كمان كما نحن نشاهد
تهديدات كبيره
لمحطه نوويه في حاله لتسريب الاشعاع في
هذا المنطقه سوف تكون مصممه يعني هو خاصه
جنوب اوكرانيا والواسطه الاوكرانيا يعني
هذا الكارثه بصفه عامه
لسكان لسكان اوكرانيا لسكان محافظه نحن
نشاهد بصراحه بان روسيا ترتكب جرائم حرب
واباده الجماعيه
ولكن بصراحه هذا العمل الارهابي بالنسبه
لك انا منتظر تقريبا من شهر نوفمبر عندما
اوكرانيا حررت مدينه خرسون ومحافظه خرسون
سوف تدمر هذه هذه المحطه الكهربائيه
تقريبا في شهر نوفمبر ولكن روسيا دمرت هذه
محطه الان في هجوم مضاد قوات المصالحه
اوكرانيه كما يقولون خبراء كصف من
المستحيل سوف يدمر بهذا الفريق او حايمرس
يعني لا يستطيعون بهذا الطريق
محطه كهربائيه وهذا اكيد كان انفجار ولكن
تدمير الساده
يذكرنا كثيرا
كذلك انتقل الى موسكو والكاتب السياسي
بسام البني سيد بسام يعني كيف يمكن ان
تتعامل لروسيا مع هذه الاستراتيجيه كما
يعني تقول الروايه الروسيه للجانب
الاوكراني بتفجير مناطق وتتهم روسيا يعني
راينا تعليقات من الامن الفيدراليه الروسي
والذي قال بان الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
انشات وحده جويه لتنفيذ اعمال تخريبيه
بالتالي كيف يمكن ان تتعامل روسيا مع ذلك
يعني باعتقادي الشخصي ان اول ما يموت في
الحرب هو الحقيقه يعني يقتحمون منطقه
ويقولون لك انهم
معارضين رؤوس مسلحين يريدون الانتفاض على
حكومتهم يفجرون سد كخوف كما يتهمون روسيا
مباشره بانها ترتكب جرائم حرب
يستهدفون محطه زبروج في السابق ويقولون لك
ان روسيا تستهلكها رغم ان هارون روسيا
تسيطر على محطه
ماذا يفيد روسيا هذا الامر لا يفيدها بشيء
يعني سوى اللهم بضرب سمعتها ان فعلت ذلك
انا اعتقد ان روسيا ذاهبه قريبا لاعلان
كيف دوله ارهابيه اذا ما ثبت بالدليل
القاطع لدى روسيا بان كيف يعني اذا ما
توفر لدى وزاره الدفاع معلومات تؤكد وتثبت
للعالم اجمع ان كيف وراء تفجير هذا السد
عن طريق صور الاقمار الصناعيه او عن طريق
المعلومات المتوفره لدى شبكات الرادارات
التي لابد انها ترصد هذه المنطقه اذا ما
اثبتت روسيا للعالم ان هذا الاستهداف هو
من طرف كيف اذا انا باعتقادي الشخصي لم
يبقى لي روسيا الا ان تعلن اوكرانيا نظامك
نظام ارهابي وبالتالي كل من يدعمه داعم
للارهاب وما يترتب على ذلك طيب ابقوا معي
ضيوفي الكرام لاعود اليكم في سياق هذه
النشره
في اول ردود الفعل المشاهدين على تفجير
هذا الساده الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديميرنسكي
اعتبر ان استهداف كي يؤكدوا ضروره طرد
القوات الروسيه من كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
حرب واباده بيئيه وقالت ان روسيا استهدفت
السد لابطاء العمليات الهجوميه من جانبه
حمل وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا ديميتري كوليبا
حمل روسيا مسؤوليه تفجير السد ووصفها
بانها اكبر كارثه تكنولوجيه في اوروبا منذ
عقود في المقابل ذكرت تقارير روسيه ان
استهداف سد نوفاك خوفكا تم بصاروخ من
قاذفه اولخا الاوكرانيه وقال عمده نوفاك
خوف كاليوكاله تاسين استهداف السد كارثه
خلقتها السلطات الاوكرانيه ومن يديرونه
مشيرا الى ان 300 منزل بات مهدد في منطقه
الفيضان لكنه اكد انه لا خطر بقطع امدادات
المياه على شبه جزيره القرم
طيب نشير الى هذا العاجل لمشاهدينا وتقول
تاس عن مسؤول محلي بان اوكرانيا قصفت
خرسون بصواريخ ستورما شادو وايضا تقول بان
سد نوفاكا خوفكا مستمر في التداعي ولا
يمكن السيطره على تدفق المياه اعود الى
ضيوف ملكييف الدبلوماسي والمستشار السابق
فلاديمير شوماكوفو من موسكو الكاتبه
السياسي بسام البني ابدا معك سيبدا يعني
سيد بسام ذكر بان موسكو قد تتجه الى اتهام
كييف بانها عاصمه ارهابيه ودوله ارهابيه
وتتخذ اجراءات بناء على ذلك برايك ما ان
تمت هذه الخطوه كيف يؤثر على مسار الحرب
وموقف اوكرانيا امام العالم
نحن نشاهد بان هذا العمل انتقامي رؤوس
لنتذكر قبل تقحق ومين مدينه خرسون نظيفه
غربيه محافظه خرسان وروسيا دمرت في هذا
المنطقه
الاساسيه داخل مدينه خريستون وفي دواح
مدينه خرسون عندنا بصراحه
او حتى خمسه
بدون كهرباء بسبب تدمير بنيه تحقيق
الاساسيه قبل روسيا من مدينه خرسون وامينه
هذا المنطقه
الان روسيا هي ترتكب جرائم جرائم خارقه
يعني تنفيص اباده جماعيه او جرائمه حرق
وامتار كل شيء ها هو ها هي سياسه روسيه
اكيد هذا بصراحه كارثه على نطاق واسع
لاوكرانيا ليست لروسيا كما انا كنت قبل
جيش روسي موجود في عمق المحافظه الشرقيه
يوجد اي ضرر للجيش روسي في هولندا نحن
نشاهد بان الجيش الروسي هو مستعد لتراجع
من هذا المنطقه وهذا عمل
يعني نحن بالفعل نرى تداعيات تفجير السعد
على الجانب الروسي يعني نرى
استعدادات للنزوح نرى استعدادات لخروج
الاهالي من المناطق المجاوره لهذا السد من
القرى يعني 300 منزل يتم اخلاقه حتى
اللحظه فنرى بالفعل هذه التداعيات تحدث
ولكن ما التداعيات على الجانب الاوكراني
انقلها لي برايك
بصفه
لمحافظه بالمناسبه الان موجود عمليه
الاجلاء تقريبا من ثمانيين
تقع تحت سيطره روسيا
لاخر سلط تحت السيطره تحت مدينه خرسون تحت
السيطره قوه مصالحه يدور حديثا الضيفه
الشرقيه
جيش روسيا ولكن كما كنت موجود الان عمليه
الاجلاء تقريبا من 80 القريه في محافظه
خيرسون كما من ضيفه شرقيه اينما موجود روس
وكمان من ضيفه غربيه
اين موجود تركوات مصالحه اوكرانيه يعني
على كل حال على نطاق الواسع في ان واحد
كما انا كنت قابل عندي شواغل بان روسيا
مستعده تدمير حتى محطه كهربائيه محطه
نوويه قبل قبل اطارات من محافظه
فاطمه يعني حتى هذه اللحظه موسكو كانت
تتحدث مرات عده عن ان استهداف هذه المحطه
وخروج هذه الكميات الكبيره من المياه قد
يؤدي الى كارثه موضعيه في المنطقه اولا
يعني موسكو لديها العديد من القواعد
العسكريه في شبه جزيره القرم القناه
المائيه التي توصل التي تصل طبعا القلم
وتمدها بالمياه قد تتعرض للجفاف وهذا قد
ما يحل بكارثه على الاراضي الزراعيه
الغنيه كما يقيمها كما تقيمها موسكو وكيف
في تلك المنطقه ايضا لهذه المحطه اهميه
كبيره فهي طبعا تقوم بانتاج كميات الضخمه
من الكهرباء يمكنها في المستقبل حسب خطط
موسكو الوصول بهذه الاسلاك وبهذه
الامدادات الى شبه جزيره القرم المقطوع
عنها الكهرباء منذ بدايه الصراع عام 2014
تقريبا لكن طبعا في اخر الانباء فاطمه منذ
قليل تحدث
تحدثت سلطات خرسون المواليه لروسيا بان
بانها غير مضطره في الوقت الحالي وليست
بحاجه لاجلاء كميات كبيره من السكان نعم
بالفعل ضرب هذا الجسر وخروج المياه هي
كارثه لكنها ليست كارثه يعني بهذا الحجم
الكبير التي قد تطال كافه المواطنين لا
نعرف حتى هذه اللحظه ما تقصد حكومه خرسون
هل الحديث يدور عن ان 50 الف شخص او
خروجهم من تلك المناطق حسب ما يتم تداولها
على تداوله على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هي الاعداد التي تتحدث عنها حكومه المدينه
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه حكومه تلك المناطق
تتحدث بان هذه الضربه لن توقف موسكو عن
الاستمرار بعملياتها العسكريه وحمايه
الضفه المتواجده فيها القوات الروسيه طبعا
بالعوده الى موضوع
اليك عبد الجواد ولكن اسمح لي ان انتقل
الى دنيتكم مراسل العربيه من هناك رائد
الاغبر رائد يعني كنت اتحدث مع عبد الجواد
ايضا عن القصف والهجمات الروسيه ولا
الهجمات الاوكرانيه المضاده كذلك وتداعيات
هذا السد بدايه ما تداعيات هذا السد ماذا
سطح حتى الان يعني بحكم قربك من المنطقه
منطقه السد ماذا رصت حتى الان من اضرار
وكيف هي ايضا العمليات الاقتتاليه
الاقتتاليه على ارض المعركه
نعم فاطمه يعني الحدث كبير وضخم جدا رغم
ان السلطات حتى الان اذا تحدثنا عن
السلطات المحليه
الروسيه بانها ليست هناك اي اضرار كبيره
او وقيمه لكن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وخاصه تيليجرام يظهر فيديوهات بان المحطه
الكهربائيه قد غرقت بالكامل وان منسوب
المياه ارتفع
ليصل الى عشره امتار وذلك ما جعل المحطه
تكون مغموره بالكامل بالمياه اذا لم تكن
هذه الفيديوهات التي تعرض على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي مفبركه بالفعل السلطات
المحليه في خرسون وزبروت
اهم المواطنين وانه ليست هناك اي حاله
هسيريه عندها المواطنين الذين يملكون
بيوتا او يعيشون في تلك البيوت المساخمه
لنهر
المياه هو ان عمليه الاجلاء الحديث عن
الاف المواطنين ستتم عمليه اجلائهم اذا
لزم الامر هذه تصريحات السلطات المحليه
والحديث عن عمده خرسون قال بانه
يعني المواطنين لم يصلوا الى تلك الحاله
التي يحتاج الى الاجلاء يعني المواصلات
والمركبات جاهزه ومكان الهواء
الامر لكن
للتوضيح فقط الطبيعه الجغرافيه للمنطقه
فان نهر دينيبرو هو يفصل
مناطق السيطره الاوكرانيه عن مناطق
السيطره الروسيه النهر بالكامل اي ان
الجانب الاوكراني ايضا عنده كثير من
الاضرار بنفس الوضع التي تتعرض له المنطقه
في جانب سيطره القوات الروسيه مساله اخرى
هامه وهي ان المحطه النوويه هي الاكثر
يعني
يعني التهديد الاكبر اذا تضررت هذه المحطه
النوويه وماذا سيحدث في اذا حصلت اي
تسريبات اشعاعيه من هذه المحطه يعني رائد
مسؤول المسؤول في خيرسون بحسب عبد الجواد
قبل قليل كان يحاول طمانه الناس بان يعني
حجم الاضرار كارثيا ولم يطال جميع
المواطنين وليس بالحجم الذي نتحدث عنه
ولكن لا نفهم تحديدا ماذا يعني بهذه
التصريحات ابقى مع رائد لانتقل الى
بروكسيل ومراسل العربيه نور الدين الفريضي
نور الدين يعني انت تنضم الينا من بروكسيل
وترصد لنا اجتماع وزراء المجلس الاوروبي
بالتالي فيما يخص تفجير السد هذا مرضت من
ردود فعل اوروبيه خصوصا بانه يعتبر تحول
كبير في حرب اوكرانيا نور الدين
في تغريده قبل قبل حين قال من ان هذا
الحادث وعدوانا غير مسبوق
من ان تدمير البنى التحتيه يمثل
حسب قول شارل ميشيل جرائم حرب وان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيحاسب روسيا واوكلائها على هذه
الجرائم في هذه التغريده يفهموا مباشره ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي
يفسد او الجانب الروسي اوكلائه مسؤوليه
تفجير السلب من دون انتظار اي تحقيق يعني
ولكن بصفه عامه
الشعور او الموقف هو صدمه الكبيره هو
التساؤل حول التداعيات التي ستنجم عن هاته
عن هذا الحادث عن انهيار الصدق سواء كان
بالنسبه للمواطنين او المدنيين في على
ضفتي النهر هذا النهر الذي يفصل بين
الاوكرانيين
والمناطق التي تحتلها روسيا وضم
تها لسيادتها
مستمره والاضرار البيئيه مستمره على
المنطقه
المجاوره وايضا على السكان في القرى
المجاوره اعود الى موسكو ومراسلنا من هناك
عبد الجواد الرشد يعني كما استمعت معنا
عبد الجواد يقول
نور الدين بان
المسؤولين الاوروبيين في اجتماع المجلس
الاوروبي اتهموا روسيا فورا من دون اي
تحقيقات ومن دون اي محاولات لمعرفه
الحقيقه يعني الى ماذا تشير هذه الخطوه
وكيف موسكو تفهم هذه الرساله من الرؤساء
الاوروبيين عبد الجواد
فاطمه الكثير من القراءات يعني منذ اعلان
ضرب هذه المحطه بدات تتحدث عن ان كيف قامت
بهذه الخطوه للرد او للفت الانتباه حول
الاخفاقات بما يخص مساله يعني الهجوم
المضاد الذي تحدثت عنه كيف طويلا هذا ما
يتم الحديث عنه الان في وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه خاصه بعد تقرير وزاره الدفاع يوم
امس الذي تحدث عن مقتل عدد كبير من القوات
الاوكرانيه على عده محاور وهذه الاعداد
يعني قد تكون قياسيه في رقم واحد والتي
وصلت الى قرابه 1500 شخص من القوات
الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى الكثير من
المعدات ان كانت ثقيله وان كانت تعاديه
طبعا بما يخص قضيه بيلغراد ما زالت
الاعمال والضربات هناك مستمره وهذا طبعا
الداخل الروسي ربط هذا الموضوع نوعا ما
بما يحدث في الجنوب الاوكراني خاصه ان تلك
المنطقه هي حدوديا نوعا ما وتعرضها لمثل
هذه الضربات هو كان شيء متوقعا خاصه من
سكان القرى والمناطق الحدوديه لكن موسكو
حتى هذه اللحظه فاطمه ما زالت تلتزم الصمت
على ما يبدو بان هناك تصريحات ستخرج من
الدفاع والكرملين حسب ما نتابع الان على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي قد يضطر الرئيس
الاعلان اجتماع مع مجلس الامن اليوم او في
الايام القليله الماضيه لمناقشه هذا
الموضوع لكن كما تحدثي فاطمه الكارثه بدات
وهي مستمره الكثير من الاسئله في الداخل
الروسي اصبحت تطرح هل ستصل الضربات الى
محطه زبروجي النوويه ونشهد يعني ذات مره
حدوث انفجار قد يعني يوصل المنطقه الى
مرحله لا يحمد عقبها هذه الاسئله يطرحها
كثيرا الجانب الروسي واضح
المناطق يعني حسب الروايه نعم كثيرا ما
شاهدنا الجانب الروسي يحذر من ان الجانب
الاوكراني سيقوم باستهداف محطه زابوريا
سيقوم باستهداف اماكن حساسه جدا في
اوكرانيا ويقوم باتهام الجانب الروسي فيها
انتقل الى كييف لينضم الينا مجددا الصحفي
محمد البابا احييك من جديد محمد يعني
المسؤولين الاوروبيين يتهمون روسيا بشكل
قطعي بهذا بتفجير هذا السد ولكن روسيا
تقول بانه تم استهداف السد بصواريخ اولخال
الاوكرانيه وبصواريخ
الا يمكن ان يعني تخرج موسكو باثباتات
قاطعه بانها لم تستهدف السد وانما الجانب
الاوكراني خصوصا وانها تذكر انواع
الصواريخ التي استخدمت في تفجير السد محمد
هذه تكهنات اولا لا احد يمكنه ان يعرف
نوعيه الصواريخ بحكم الموقع الجغرافي
المكان الذي تم استهدافه هناك طيارات
مائيه كبيره وضخمه وضغط مائي كبير لذلك
يعني هذه الفكره هناك وبيانات تخرج يعني
حتى الان بخير
الاوكراني يقول انه يمكن للوحده البندقيه
الاليه رقم 205 اي يعني وحده الانشات
الروسيه التابعه للقوات الروسيه الرقم 205
هي من قامت بتفجير سد نوفيكا بحسب مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني
ميخائي واكد ان تفجير محطه
[موسيقى]
نور الكهرومائيه قد يتسبب في تعديل في خطط
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الهجوم المضاد
للجيش الاوكراني لكنه لن يغير اي شيء من
الناحيه الاستراتيجيه ولكن انه يثير
الرغبه في انهاء
اوكرانيا في وقت كبير يعني انهاء احتلال
القوات الروسيه لاراضي اوكرانيا بدورها
صرحت نتالياه المركز الصحفي في الجيش
الاوكراني في جنوب اوكرانيا من خلال تفجير
محطه
[موسيقى]
الكهرومائيه تحاول القوات الروسيه اعاقه
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد ويرودين من خلال
هذا التفجير تريد القوات الروسيه زياده
مساحه سطح الماء حتى لا تلجا قوات الدفاع
الاوكرانيه الى التقدم وعبور النهر
الى المناطق التي تسيطر عليها نقطه تحديدا
محمد يعني ذكر ضيفي قبل قليل بان تفجير
السد وتدفق المياه لا يؤثر على تقدم الجيش
الاوكراني فيما يخص الهجوم المضاد ابقوا
معي كرما لاعود الى ضيوفي من كييف
الدبلوماسي والمستشار السابق فلاديمير
شوماكوف ومن موسكو الكاتب السياسي بسام
البني سيد بسام يعني هذه الاتهامات
القاطعه من المسؤولين الاوروبيين في
المجلس الاوروبي لروسيا باتهامها بارتكاب
جرائم حرب هل يعني اننا لن نرى تحقيق فيما
يخص تفجير السد
[موسيقى]
يعني اكيد روسيا وبوتين سوف يحاسب شخصيا
لكل جرائم التي روسيا ترتكب ضد الشعب
الاوكرانيا ونحن بصراحه غير مجنونين
لتضمير الصاد المباركه لانه عموما هذا
المنطقه هل يمكن لاوكرانيا ان تطالب
بالقيام بتحقيق ام ربما سترفض تحقيق انا
اوكرانيا بدات عمليه التحقيق ولكن اكيد
سوف يكون تحقيقا دقيق عندما اوكرانيا سوف
تحرر هذا المنطقه من الجيش الروسي لان
الان في هذا المنطقه موجودين قوات مصالحه
روسيه وكما نحن نشاهد حتى بالفيديوهات
وكمان بالصور
بنيه تغطيه الاساسيه
ومنها ومنها مواليد بصفه عامه كما انا كنت
هذا كارثه لسكان مدينه خيرسون بالمناسبه
الان تحت المايه بعض بعض المناطق سكنيه
مدينه خرسون للاسف الشديد وهناك ارتاحت
المنصوب المياه الى السطح في منازل منازل
الخاصه في هذا المنطقه طيب سيد يعني مسؤول
محلي تقول بان اوكرانيا هي من استهدفت سد
نوفا خوفكا لصرف الانظار عن فشل هجماتها
المضاده هل فشلت الهجمات المضاده برايك
لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تناجوم الموضات انا اعتقد بان مازال في
عملياته واوكرانيا في بحث النقاط ضعف في
الدين روسيه لم تكون بصراحه مازال هجوم
متواقع ولكن بصراحه تدمير هذا الصاد اكيد
في صالح الجيش الروسي في صالح روسيا
لتعارك الهجوم
مدينه خرسون ومن جنوب مدينه خرسون هذا
صحيح ولكن كما قالت
[موسيقى]
الهجوم المضاده الاوكرانيا الحقيقي لم
يبدا بعد طيب اسمح لي انتقل الى السيد
بسام سيد بسام برايك هل نحن بصدد موقف
مشاهد مشابه لحادثه تفجير نور ستريم 2
فيما يخص التحقيقات وعدم وضوح المعلومات
ومجرد خروج تكهنات يعني حتى وان فتح تحقيق
هل سيخرج بمعلومات اكيده
وصارمه واضحه
حتى وان اراتهم روسيا الصواريخ التي
استهدفت هذا السد بالفيديو بانها قادمه من
الجانب الاوكراني هذا قولا واحدا الغرب
يؤكد يؤيد اوكرانيا بكل ما تقوم به ويسمح
لها حتى الجديده دعني دعيني يعني اقول
للسيد بلادي ان يجب ان نكون منطقيين في
بدايه الامر يعني روسيا ليس من مصلحتها
زعزعت الامن الداخلي الروسي والمنطقه التي
ضمتها روسيا تعتبرها روسيه حسب الدستور
الروسي هناك هجوم اوكراني مضاد قد بدا
بالفعل لا يمكن الحديث عن موضوع جس النبض
فقط لان السيناريو الذي بدات به اوكرانيا
هو ضرب في العمق وعندما تم استهداف الكريم
بالمسيرات وبعدها الضرب في على الحدود في
منطقه
شبينكو والى اخره هذه الضربات كلها حسب
السيناريو الامريكي الذي يقوم به عندما
تقوم بهجوم ضربه في العمق زعزعه الوضع
الداخلي اضعاف
الروح المعنويه لدى الشعب ومن ثم الهجوم
العسكري قامت بكل ما قامت به من اجل ارباك
القوات الروسيه وتشتيتها ومقامت بالهجوم
المضاد بالفعل المارحه كما قال الزميل عبد
الجواد من موسكو قبل قليل البارحه خسرت
اوكرانيا وتسع اليه عسكريه ثقيله منها
ثمانيه
مقاتل قتلوا هذا يعني ان اوكرانيا فعلا
بدات بالهجوم مضاده وفشلت وتريد ان تقدم
عذرا للغرب بانها لا تستطيع القيام
بالهجوم المضاد لان هدف الهجوم المضاد كان
الوصول الى بحر ازوف وعندما تم تفجير هذا
السبت كخوفكا يعني ان
الاليات لا تستطيع العبور نتيجه
المستنقعات التي ستحدث نتيجه الفيضانات
واذكر السيد شومكوف بان اوكرانيا استهدفتا
على مدى سنه كامله بصواريخ الهايمرز والان
كما قال احد المسؤولين المحليين لا اعلم
مدى صدقه لانه تم استخدام صواريخ ستورم
شادون بريطانيه بعيده المدى ايضا في
استهداف هذا السد لننتظر بيان وزاره
كميات كبيره من المياه تصل الى 18 مليون
متر مكعب اي انه وبختصار والد الكهرباء في
المناطق الجنوبيه وكذلك يسقي قوات او
قنوات الريت اما عن نهر الديني برو فينبع
من مرتفعات باللاديفيب روسيا ثم يعبر
بيلاروسيا ومنها الى اوكرانيا في مدينه
دينيبرو بتروفيس تحديدا حيث يصب في البحر
الاسود
[موسيقى]
شراء
نعود الى دنيتك ومراسلنا من هناك رائد
الاخبار رائد يعني يخرج ويقول بان روسيا
هي من فجرت السد خلال الليل ومن الداخل
ويقول بان تفجير السد هذا ايضا سيؤثر على
الامن الغذائي العالمي بالتالي يعني هل من
معلومات او تصريحات اخرى خرجت من مسؤولين
حيث انت رائد
نعم فاطمه ماذا لا الحدث هو
يعني
تهديدات من الطرفين واتهامات متبادله من
قبل السلطات المحليه ومن قبل روسيا
والجانب الاوكراني ايضا يتهم روسيا الحديث
عن ان
هذا الدمار الذي حل بالجسر الكائن
[موسيقى]
الماصه يوم امس كل الجبهات كانت مشتعله
بهجومات اوكرانيه الحديث ان السد ضرب
بصواريخ هايمرز وان
العمليه كانت من اجل اغراق حتى المحطه
النوويه وعكس ما تقول الروايه الاوكرانيه
نتحدث عن السلطات المحليه ماذا تقول في
خرسون بان الهدف هو الوصول الى المحطه
النوويه والسيطره عليها كما ان جاء الروسي
يقول بان المحطه النوويه محصنه ومجهزه حتى
لضربات نوويه وليست
بشكل التخطيط لهذه العمليات المنتشره
لتشتيت خطط دفاع الجيش الروسي الذي هو
يستعد منذ اشهر
للدفاع عن المناطق التي سيطر عليها ولا
يعني يفكر بالسيطره على مزيد من الاراضي
ونشهد هنا بمنطقه النزاع فاطمه الخنادق
الدفاعيه التي تنتشر
وتجهز حتى الان هناك عمليات كبيره لتجهيز
خنادق للجيش الروسي كل مسافه نتحدث عن
كيلومترات فنادق
والاخرى تجهز
وربما يكون هناك عمليه مضاده كبيره للجيش
الاوكراني الاروسي يؤكدون بان الضرب قبل
اوكرانيا لهذا الجسر تستهدف تسهيل الوصول
الى المحطه النوويه وليس عرقله وصول
القوات الروسيه الى الاوكرانيه الى اهداف
علامات تتحدث عنه رائد يعني من هذه
التفجيرات والهجوم المضاده الاوكراني
المكثف الذي رايناه في اليومين الماضيين
يعني عموما جاء تفجير السد مشاهدينا في
وقت تشهد فيه الحرب تصعيدا من الجانبين
الروسي والاوكراني لكن التصعيد الاخير
للهجمات الاوكرانيه طرح تساؤلا اليومين
الاخيرين هل بدا الهجوم المضاد فعليا
مسؤولون امريكيون رجحوا ان هذا التصعيد
الاخير يحمل دلائل على بدء ساعه الصفر
للهجوم المضاد بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز مثلا صحيح ان لم تعلن رسميا عن بدء
هجومها المضاد وقالت سابقا انها لن تصدر
اي اعلان رسمي بذلك لكنها شنت هجمات مكثفه
تحديدا في منطقه دونيتك شهدناها اليومين
الماضيين وبناء على معلومات استخباراتيه
بين كييف واشنطن عن الاطار الزمني للهجوم
المضاد قال مسؤولون للصحيفه ان الهجمات
التي شنتها القوات الاوكرانيه لاحد الماضي
جاءت بالفعل ضمن ذلك الاطار الزمني وبناء
على معلومات من الاقمار الصناعيه العسكريه
الامريكيه رصدت واشنطن زياده في الحركه من
المواقع العسكريه الاوكرانيه ورجح
محللونها عسكريون ان الوحدات الاوكرانيه
بدات حمله اوليه لتحديد مواقع وقوه القوات
الروسيه وهو تكتيك تقليدي كان الامريكيون
يدربون القوات الاوكرانيه على استخدامه
لكن حذر المسؤولون من اهم الصعوبات في
تحديد البدايه الدقيقه للهجوم المضاد وهي
كيف يمكن ان يبدا القتال بخدع او تحويلات
من كيف نعود الى ضيوفنا الدبلوماسيه
والمستشار السابق فلاديمير شوماكوف ومن
موسكو الكاتب السياسي بسام البني سيد
شوماكوب يعني التحليلات الامريكيه تشير
عكس ما انت قلته بان الهجوم المضاده
الاوكراني لم يبدا بعد اذا في ظل هذه
المعلومات الامريكيه بان هناك تحركات
عسكريه اوكرانيه وانه هناك مضاد هجمات
مضاده اوكرانيه ما علاقه ذلك بتفجير السد
يعني ما علاقه الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني
بتفجير السد
منطق روسي هو غريب كما هم يقولون اوكرانيا
فاشله في هجوم مضاد في
هذا صابر اوكرانيا
لتدمير مدينه خرسونه التي تعبئه
لاوكرانيا ولتعرك الهجومات قوات مصالحه
وهذا محاوله نصابه لتبرير جريمه روسيه
التي جعلت روسيا روسيا كما انا كنت قبل
انا لا اعتقد بانه هجوم
ممكن موجود عمليات هجينه في منطقه
معروف بان اوكرانيا امس حررت حوالي ثلاثه
كيلومتر مربع
في في هذا المحافظه في جنوبه اوكرانيا
ولكن هذا الانفجار وهذا تدمير الصادق اكيد
هذه مح اوله روسيه لوقف او لتعرق الهجوم
مضاد قوات مصالحه اوكرانيه من ضيفه غربيه
على ضيفه شرقيه
مدينه خرسون
طيب قبل ان اذهب اليك سيد بسام البني
لنتوقف سريعا مشاهدينا مع هذه الصور التي
نشرها الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
للاجتماع الطارئ المجلس الامن القومي
وكان قد قال زيلينسكي في بيان له انه في
الساعه الثانيه صباحا وخمسين دقيقه من فجر
اليوم قام مخربون روس كما وصفهم بتفجير
داخلي لمنشات محطه نوفاك خوفكا وان نحو 80
منطقه سكنيه مهدده في منطقه الفيضانات
واشرزنسكي الى انه تم تم الامر بتنفيذ
عمليات الاخلاء من مناطق الخطر كما لفتا
الى الاتفاق على مجموعه من الاجراءات
الدوليه والامنيه لمحاسبه روسيا على هذا
الهجوم الارهابي كما وصفه في البيان
اعود الى ضيفي من موسكو الكاتب السياسي
بسام البني سيد بسام يعني اسالك عن هذا
البيان الذي خرج منسكي والتاكيد على انه
يقومون بالاجراءات
التحقيق
والاثبات التهمه على روسيا يعني كنت اتحدث
مع ضيفي شوماكوب قبل قليل بان ما يحدث
يعني ما علاقته بالهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
ماذا تبتغي اوكرانيا سيد بسام من هذا
الهجوم وهذا التفجير على السد ومن هذا
التصعيد في تبعات السد يعني هي تقول بانه
سيؤدي الى كارثه غذائيه عالميه
يعني اولا حول ما يعلمه
احدثك عن شيء هام المنزليه يبدو انه قد
حضر لهذا الاستفزاز منذ زمن ولذلك وجد او
كان لديه المعلومات التي سيقدمها صباحا
غدوه بعد ان تم استهداف السد من اجل اثبات
رؤيه اوكرانيا بان روسيا هي وراء تفجير
هذا السذاجه دليل ضده وليس معه بهذه
السرعه وجد كل المعلومات المتعلقه بتفجير
السد لماذا لم يعلن عنها مسبقا في الوقت
الذي روسيا دائما وابدا كانت تعلن عن ان
هناك استفزازات اوكرانيه تحضر لها ضد محطه
زبروج النوويه ضد سد كخوفكا وكانت تصور
صواريخ الهايمر التي تسالايمرز الذي التي
تستهدف هذه هذا السد اضفي الى ذلك ان
سؤالك حول الهجوم المضاده كانت قد اعلنت
ان الهجوم المضاد هدفه الوصول الى شبه
جزيره القرن وتحريرها وبدايه يجب عليهم
الوصول الى بحر از فقط الطريق البري بين
روسيا الام وشبه جزيره الخربه هذا يعني
انهم يجب ان يعبروا عبر النيبر ويصلوا الى
ومن ثم الى شاطئ بحر ازوف هذا كل ما في
الامر اليوم بعد ان فشلوا في ذلك المتوقع
عندما تقومي بهجوم مضاد في العلم العسكري
يعني النجوم مضاد هو كحاله ملاكمين عندما
تهاجمي المدافع
يتاح له المجال لان يعني يضرب فلوسيا كان
لديها
الامكانيه بالضرب العمق الاوكراني اذا ما
قامت اوكرانيا بالهجوم المضاد ستصد هذا
الهجوم وستقوم هي بهجوم ايضا معاكس ربما
اوكرانيا فجرت هذا السد من اجل عدم
استرجاع روسيا للضفه اليسرى لنهر دنيبر من
التي خرجت منها في العام الماضي هذا كل ما
في الامر او انهم فشلوا فعلا وفهموا انهم
ليس بامكانهم القيوم بالقيام باي هجوم
مضاد فارادوا تفجير من اجل ارسال زريعه
للغرب بان نحن لا نستطيع روسيا فجرت وهناك
مستنقعات
حقيقه كثيره وكبيره ولكن ربما التصريحات
الروسيه التي نترقبها قد توضح بعض من هذا
الغموض في المشهد حول تفجير السد شكرا
جزيلا لكما من موسكو الكاتبه السياسيه
بسام البني ومنكييف الدبلوماسي والمستشار
السابق فلاديمير شوماكوب
لنستمع مشاهدينا الى تحذير لافت لحاكم
خرسون
خمس ساعات ستصل المياه الى مستوى حرج
قام الجيش الروسي بعمل ارهابي جديد فجر
السد كاغوفكا وفي غضون خمس ساعات سيصل
مستوى الماء الى المستوى الحرج عمليه
الاجلاء بدات في المنطقه وفرق الطوارئ
تعمل مع الجيش والشرطه واحث الجميع على
اخذ الوثائق المهمه وانتظار حافلات
الاخلاء
اعود الى موسكو ومراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد ومن الصحفي محمد البابا ابداء معك
عبد الجواد حول هذا البيان الذي خرج
منزلنسكي ومن الجانب الاوروبي كذلك بان
موسكو هي المتهمه الاساسي وسيتم محاسبتها
على جريمه الحرب هذه هل من تصريحات حتى
اللحظه عبد الجواد وان لم يكن هناك
تصريحات متى نتوقع خروج اي تصريحات من
المسؤولين الروس
فاطمه حتى هذه اللحظه رسميا لا يوجد اي
اعلانات من قبل موسكو الدفاع ولا الخارجيه
ولا مجلس الامن لكن متوقع طبعا خلال
الدقائق القريبه الماضيه من القادمه من
الساعه القادمه يعني بعد نحو قرابه نصف
ساعه من الان قد يخرج بيسكوف بتصريحات حسب
روايه وسائل الاعلام فاطمه طبعا في اخر
الاخبار هناك مناطق في حيرسون وتحديدا
يعني وسائل الاعلام المحليه من هناك بدات
الان بنشر مقاطع فيديو تظهر وصول مستويات
المياه الى اسقفيت البيوت الخاصه يعني انا
ومحمد وسكان هذه المناطق نعرف بان هذه
البيوت ارتفاعها يصل في بعض الاحيان قرابه
العشره امتار هناك الان مقاطع فيديو من
تلك المنطقه تظهر وصول مستويات المياه الى
اسقف هذه البيوت على ما يبدو ان المنطقه
المجاوره على
نهر النيبر في منطقه خرسون مقبله على
كارثه حقيقيه خرج طبعا خرج الاعلام المحلي
من خرسون منذ قليل وتحدث بان مدينه خرسون
الرئيسيه حتى هذه اللحظه لم تصل اليها
المياه قد تشهد المنطقه هذه الحادثه خلال
الساعات القليله القادمه
تتحدث عن ان السد ما زال في حاله انهيار
وان المياه ما زالت تتدفق بالتالي لا يمكن
تقييم حجم الضرر حتى الان انتقل الى كييف
والصحفي محمد البابا محمد يعني القياده
الجنوبيه في الجيش الاوكراني تتحدث عن
تداعيات كبيره وضخمه لهذا السد وتقول بان
محاوله موسكو بعرقله تقدمهم هو سبب تفجير
السد محمد
نعم فاطمه يعني احد الاسباب التي يعني يتم
تحميل المسؤوليه للقوات الروسيه هو اعاقه
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد ولكن لنتحدث يحصل
الان المياه على الضفه اليمنى لمنطقه
خرسون المياه تتمدد شيئا فشيئا هناك بعض
الكره وكما ذكر عبد الجواب في صور من
المسيرات بدات المياه يعني غمرت العديد من
المنازل حتى المنازل المرتفعه وصل منسوب
المياه الى سقف هذه المنازل هناك الكره
بدات الان تخرق بشكل كامل وهي الكره
الاولى التي تقع يعني على بعد عشره الى 15
الى 20 كيلو متر من هذا السد المياه تتدفق
جنوبا السد يعني تم انهيار جزء كبير من
هذا السد من حواجب المياه ويعني اللوائح
الاسمنتيه والخرسانيه التي كانت تحجب هذه
كميات كبيره من المياه انهارت بشكل كامل
المياه تتدفق ولا يمكن يعني في هذه
اللحظات وقف تدفق المياه خاصه انه يتداول
ان الانهيارات في يعني المنطقه السفلى من
هذا السد مستمره بفعل ضغط المياه هناك ضغط
كبير وكما قال كان متواجد
في الض
غط و
زاره تنفي
ان تكون اي وحده عسكريه اوكرانيه قد هاجمت
هذا هذا السد وانه بحسب ميخائيل بوديات
يعني مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الفرقه 205
من قوات المشاه الروسيه هي من قامت بتفجير
خوخه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات